The administration's decision to scrap plans for a long range missile defense system...
...in Poland and the Czech Republic was defended by Secretary Clinton...
...in her speech at the Brookings Institution.
On Thursday, government officials said, they favor a system aimed at countering...
...the medium range missiles Iran currently has.
Clinton said, the new plan, relying heavily at first on sea-based missile interceptors...
...will mean that an effective system will be deployed years earlier...
...than the approach taken by the Bush administration.
She repeated the US-NATO commitment to the Warsaw and Prague governments...
...and she insisted, Russian opposition didn't play into President Obama's calculations,...
This decision was not about Russia,...
...it was about Iran and the threat that its ballistic missile program poses.
And because of this position,...
...we believe we will be in a far stronger position to deal with that threat.
And to do so with technology that works,...
...and a higher degree of confidence...
...that what we pledged to do, we can actually deliver.